on this episode we talk delegation we
took the value of languages and we get
really deep on the thoughts of passive
income you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 86 of the askgaryvee
show
we're gonna try to bum-rush this episode
because I'm on my way to Copenhagen to
speak doing a little European travel got
Madrid next week
and Matt and I had a miscommunication so
I don't my passport so he's gonna go run
and get it it's been a little hectic
here big ups to meerkat what's up
everyone and and oh the gang met Lizzie
yesterday that was fun watching you guys
interact with Lizzie I enjoyed this
she's I got home she was like excited
meeting after our little cranes 4440
thing which is why she was here she's
like man India's hair is long I'm like
it sure is India let's get into the show
but I'm throwing on to the show and keep
this rolling the rock vaynernation I'm
really enjoying you know I had a few
minutes to look at this the the
interaction between the vaynernation and
you guys is super fun for me to watch
you know I also got like a random email
like hey can you get me India's email I
have a project I need to speak to her
about I'm like I'm air traffic control
to India what's going on here something
is clearly happening here and it's magic
all right let's go then he asks Gary do
you have any tips on delegation ID any
you know I actually think the best piece
of advice that I can give to delegating
is actually gonna be very much up in the
clouds and as you know I like the clouds
and the dirt d-roc link it up
I think I'm tremendous at delegating and
I'll tell you the number one rule to
delegation recognizing that 99.9% of
things don't mean [ __ ] if you actually
think it's not that important it becomes
a hell of a lot easier to let somebody
else do it if you recognize somebody
else's seven-point-seven skills is
better off because that job is worth
that versus your 10-point Oh skills its
humility my friend ego oftentimes is the
issue with delegation even though I have
a ton of ego
I have a boatload more humility than you
think Tommy asks Gary isn't working long
hours an old school mindset why not
focus on building wealth via passive
income you know Tommy I think I think
both work you know I think that when
people say hey let's do passive income
they go into like spam City USA often
times you know I have passive income
when I'm investing in early-stage
startups that then go sell for 400 X and
I didn't do anything I made money should
I made more money on my passive income
probably than my hustle income they both
work but please make sure that your
passive income has practicality to it
because all the people that have tried
to create systems and automate their
cash there's been a very small
percentage of people that have been able
to lay on the beach while they collect
money on the internet a lot of that
stuff is completely ludicrous and I
promise you the ones in the 1% of
passive income spent a boatload of hard
work and hard time to get to that
evergreen place up in the sky and so you
know I think that there's an enormous
massive misunderstanding that there are
almost zero people that have pulled off
substantial success without putting in
real time and effort now we all have
different ambitions and goals do I think
that it's little easier to create
$60,000 a year in passive income on the
internet today I sure do and if that's
what your goal and ambition is that's
more practical than millions millions of
dollars in passive income on the
internet smoking weed in Jamaica while
it just keeps coming in is just not as
real as you think partner you like that
one right because that's what everybody
thinks it is like it's that's not real
show me because I'll show you a billion
people that like have won through hard
work show me show me this magical person
because I'll show you somebody who sells
you that dream but isn't actually doing
it wow that I'll show you you want me to
hire some models for the afternoon and
get a boat and go to some sunny place
and be like this is a
I'll show you that you want me to show
you the people on Instagram who go take
all the money they own in the world in
hundred-dollar forms in the bank and
throw it on a bed and take a picture and
then put it back in their back I'll show
you that I'll show you the front of this
passive income dream of the Internet
sorry is that right you're happy that I
cut you happy I picked up a little
crescendo as meerkat like in the the
crescendo they get here got it got it
wait you see it Derek asks Gary what
athlete past or present embodies hustle
for you Wayne Chrebet tenth guy on the
on the depth chart when he joined the
Jets in 95 and practice got there
because his dad hustled together some
VHA VHS tapes the Jets sucked so the
coach brought in anybody and his number
was retired last year
that is incredible he looks like me a
short white dude he played through
massive concussions I've gotten to know
Wayne a little bit in his post career
it's funny I always felt like Wayne was
a little overrated because he was like
the little white guy and I was like
that's racist or that you know but but
his Hustle is insanity and so I have
enormous amounts of respect for him and
he absolutely is the answer to that
question Thomas asks Gary what value do
you find in knowing a foreign language
Tomas near watching treasure log of
Adidas Peru Schiavi open mio bhagavad
its Yannick adapting of the deal
economically actually America me
heartily beats you know Americans case
Omega but even he / / Indian in not
ruski but you have so penny my oh yes
now you know yes if you give Alicia
Purdue's Kiera penny Myers P you're
laughing at me because the the way I
speak Russian is is so hardcore English
accent and and struggle but it's a it's
interesting I failed
German and the only reason I even
graduated high school is because my
Spanish teacher is the great
of all time and she just knew that I had
it and big shout out to Senor Kennedy
the one teacher that really holds a
hardcore place in my heart because truly
in New Jersey you have to graduate two
years of language and by failing out of
German my freshman and sophomore year I
needed a miracle to pass Spanish one and
two in my junior and senior year and and
God was very good to me for giving me a
teacher that had a tough reputation but
clearly she was smart as [ __ ] because
she actually knew who I was she she
literally called my mom and like I'm
giving you son a C for charisma but you
need to know he doesn't even know how to
say hello in Spanish and so I don't put
a lot of value on knowing other
languages maybe that's because of my own
personal prejudice of being someone who
struggled learning another one even
though I've got to from at least a
hearing stand boy and I can communicate
you throw me in Moscow for a month that
Russian you just heard will get a hell
of a lot better as my ear and tongue get
adapted to it I also think technology is
now coming where we're gonna be able to
translate like clearly in a decade I'll
be able to go to China and just be like
or like talking to here or just it's in
it like or put in the ear pieces like
does anybody not know that we're gonna
put your pieces in when we go to foreign
countries and we're just all going to
talk our languages and everything's
gonna be translated proper and so the
value I put on it has gone down in value
as I recognize technology's gonna fix
that issue Benjamin asks Gary I want to
start pushing people to make the same
decision I made by leaving a very secure
job to pursue their dream my question is
will my employee retention rate drop
since you started building up your
personal brand as your employee
retention rate dropped the thing we need
to understand is that intent trumps
everything and so I think one amazing
thing in this company that I'm extremely
proud of is I truly believe that these
people that work at vaynermedia really
recognize that I want to win but not at
their expense
I want to buy the Jets not at the
expense of my employees with my
employees and I equally want what's best
for them of course you know I'm looking
at these three and things were running
through my mind and obviously I
know them all at different levels but
like you know there's narratives in my
mind that I can play out right now
that leads to world of them not being
here and that makes me sad and I really
don't want that
and from an ego standpoint I truly
believe that I can bring them so much
value over the long haul that makes it
interesting for them to stay but I think
it's massively important that they
always deep down feel as though I want
them to have what they want
even though optically it doesn't benefit
me and I would say 40% of vaynermedia
believes that and that may surprise you
as a loan number but I hope you
understand the level of cynicism that is
instilled in us as human beings to not
believe everything I just said and so
I'm massively proud of the 40% and I'm
really pumped that I think that 40% was
actually 12 percent only 12 to 18 months
ago and so I'm building momentum right I
look I think if you're scared to lose
somebody who believes in their heart
that they have the skill set to go and
do it you're making a huge mistake and I
actually think you build retention by
showing that than the reverse it's a
reverse psychology game that is not a
tactic because if you don't actually
believe it that reverse psychology will
come across is [ __ ] and you'll lose
it I don't do it because I want a
reverse psychology India I do it because
I believe it and then they have to
believe it evolve in their place like
you know I believe that the evolution of
people not being here is gonna have a
lot more to do with things in life they
fall in love and get married and have to
move because their spouse really needs
to do this and they have they have the
empathy and being the bigger man and
woman in a relationship they let go let
their spouse do that unfortunately maybe
something tragic I actually think that
when you're pure when you want to win
but you want to win with not you know on
the back of people start sticking around
because the truth is if somebody works
at a job in a lot of ways they weren't
thinking purely I'm gonna put this on my
back to begin with right and you and I
don't know your age is there a picture
or was this a written word you know I
don't know your age but again if you're
if you're over 30 you were sold on a
world where it wasn't like I'm gonna go
do my own thing right so now that we
live in that world
I actually feel that the kids that are
going to work for companies now in lieu
of entrepreneurship are lutely not
entrepreneurs back into that big
argument a bunch preneur like tendencies
in entrepreneurship I'll tell you right
now show me a 23 year old that wants to
work here and I'll show you somebody who
is got entrepreneurial tendencies but
isn't pure entrepreneur so I just think
doing the right thing is always the
right thing and I think empowering your
people to follow their dreams if they
have one if they think they're good
enough if they are willing to deal with
the stress and all the dog [ __ ] that
comes along with having all the pressure
on your shoulder then you know you
empower them and move for them and and
try to be part of that narrative but if
they have tendencies what you're doing
is actually building a deeper
relationship with that person and
actually my belief is that pride
percentage you're creating longer term I
mean the stickiness of this company is
pretty intense given the agency world's
a tough place for stickiness and so I'm
very proud of that and and you know what
I spew pretty last question question of
the day what is the right in front of
you right now what is the clear dream
that you have what's the one thing you
want to accomplish that is crystal clear
it'll it will evolve it might be
different than it was six months ago
it's gonna be different in six years but
right this second as you watch this show
what's the one thing you want to
accomplish you keep asking questions
I'll keep brilliantly answering them
like that